this morning we've got an update on the
long-running on rest and protests in the
country of Peru where 50 people
thereabouts have been killed during
weeks of protests over the Peruvian
president's removal and then arrest last
month Christina raffini has been
following this story Christina proves a
young democracy good morning what's it
all about Good morning Tony well it's
called an auto gulpe or a cell
tractors of
president Pedro Castillo call it an
illegal power grab by dissolving the
country's Congress but the response to
his arrest has been a bit unexpected
with protesters taking to the streets
despite the new president's call for
calm
after more than 30 days of violent and
sometimes deadly clashes Peru is under a
state of emergency demonstrators have
blocked roadways and shut down runways
with protesters hurling rocks and fury
at security personnel
who push back with brutal and sometimes
deadly force
the protest began after the impeachment
of former president Pedro Castillo in
December
after he tried to dissolve Congress by
decree in a power grab and form an
emergency government his vice president
and former political Ally Dina bullarte
took over but Castillo supporters who
see him as a champion of poor and
Indigenous peruvians stuck with him Peru
is a divided country racially
economically geographically Eric
Farnsworth vice president of the Council
of the Americas says frustrations have
expanded beyond the presidency
and the pandemic only exacerbated those
divisions especially in Peru which had
the highest per capita death rate from
covid in the world
showed people who could get things like
vaccines you know some people who could
work from home versus a lot of people in
the informal economy who didn't have
that luxury this turned into a general
dissatisfaction protests in Peru against
the government against inequality
against unfairness
now this unrest in Peru comes after big
protests in Brazil Bolivia and elsewhere
in South America as trust in
institutions not only in the region but
around the world struggles to recover
following the pandemic and economic
downturn I mean at least 50 killed
that's a big number it's more than very
fast could that kind of chaos and local
officials are saying possible Anarchy
lead to migration out of Peru I think
you're unlikely to see the kind of
migrants we're seeing from Honduras and
those kinds of countries come our way
the issue is internally displaced people
the issue is spill over into neighboring
countries and just kind of a fall-on
effect that's never good for any of
these nations trying to uphold democracy
yeah not getting a lot of attention here
that's why I'm glad we're telling you
this is a big story thanks for giving us
the time yes yes good to see you nice to
see you too